with Earth being the only planet in our
solar system there's no telling where it
might end up we could be all the way in
the back where Uranus and Neptune used
to be or somewhere right up
front where Mercury once was it's safe
to say that no matter where we end up if
it's not the goldilock Zone there's a
pretty good chance there wouldn't be any
life here on Earth if life did form
somehow it would definitely be aquatic
that's because without any other planets
keeping us in check Earth's gravity
would be severely different when we say
no other planets we mean no moons either
the moon's gravitational pull is
responsible for the tides here on Earth
without it our Waters would remain still
the oceans wouldn't rise or fall they
would just stay where they were so
really Earth as we know it wouldn't
exist if there were no other planets